What are things that you
have either learned or practiced
in your own life,
when you doubt yourself,
when you doubt the momentum,
when shit is
just not working?
I mean, dude.
No matter how prepared
you are, as
Mike Tyson says, right,
everyone thinks they have
a plan until they get
punched in the face.
That's just how
life is, man.
You have to be able
to take the hits
and keep pushing forward.
The last year
has been brutal.
That's just the honest truth,
ever since Trump launches token.
Dude, it's been down only
for the alts.
It's been down only
for the L1s,
a little bit of opportunities
here and there.
But what are you
gonna do?
You're gonna cry about it?
We're here to
get shit done,
one step at a time, dude.
Wake up in that tomorrow
and just get
one thing accomplished.